بعد انقاص وزنهم اعطينا منهم
عام 2017 فجاه امير عيد مطرب فرقه كايروكي
الجمهور بمظهره واثار التكهنات بعد ما
خسرت 66 كيلو جراما من وزنه حيث ان البعض
اتهمه بتعاطي المخدرات لكنه ارجع ذلك الى
مضاعفات عمليات جراحيه في 2019
الفنانه احلام لافته الانظار بالجمهور بعد
خساره نحو 20 كيلوغراما من وزنها وقالت
انها فقدت شهيتها اتجاه الطعام وتتبع نظام
غذائيا وانتقدت من يرجع خساره وزنها الى
استخدام برنامج الفوتوشوب
الفنانه المصريه مايكل السابق اختارت
اجراء عمليه تكميم المعده بناء على رغبه
ابنتها وايضا حفاظا على صحتها ولفتت النظر
بخسارتها الوزن خلال ظهورها الاخير في
مسلسل جعفر العمده المطربه الانجليزيه
اديل خسرت اكثر من خمسه واربعين كيلو
جراما خلال عام 2019 بفضل ممارستها
الرياضه ثلاث مرات يوميا وتقول ان هذا
التحول ساعدها على الصعيد النفسي قبل
الجسدي
[موسيقى]
في الاستوديو تنضم الينا الاستشاريه في
علم الذكاء العاطفي ريتا عبد الباقي ريتا
صباح الورد كيفك يعني الذكاء العاطفي
كل الامور اليوم تشعرنا بانه من يضعف يخسر
له كيلوين ثلاثه يثير هذا الضجه لكن صوره
يعني سماح انور
ماذا تتوقع لماذا الناس كانت تتفاعل مع
هذه الصوره بهذه الكثره يعني كل انسان بحب
شخص بينهم عليه يعني لما يكون في خساره
وزن بهالطريقه اول شيء رجع عبالنا هو
المرض بس مش ضروري يكون في مرض يمكن يكون
في حاله
خاصه ما بنعرف عنا نحن وانتجت هال
هالخساره بالوزن فما بنعرف الخبريه كلها
بس نحن كبشر بنحبها بنتفاعل معه لانه كل
انسان بعقله فيه مرنيورونز اللي هم
الخلايا العصبيه العساسيه هاي هي الخلايا
العصبيه المراتيه thank you اللي بتخلينا
نتواصل مع العالم يعني اذا حدا بيشبهني او
عنده غرض او عنده سبب عم بيناضل من اجله
انا عم بتواصل معه فلما يصير شيء عنده عم
بتاثر انا هذا لما هذا لما احنا يكون
نظرتنا للاشي اللي صار معه فقدانه للوزن
نظره سلبيه هل ممكن تكون ايضا نظره
ايجابيه يعني مثلا ف
[موسيقى]
يعني للاسف
والشكل الخارجي كثير هو الانطباع الاول
انا اول ما التقي فيك عم شوف شكلك الخارجي
قبل ما تحكي سو دغري يعني بتفاجا اذا كنت
بعرفك بطريقه معينه وشفتك خسرت 15 كيلو
فهيدي كل البرمجه اللي نحن ربينا عليها
انه انه هيك الشكل لازم يكون او في عنا
مبدا او معايير معينه للجسم للكمال
[موسيقى]
لاحظ السيء كثير اكثر من الاجابه يعني ما
حدا راح يقول لك
نعم لانه هيك برمجتنا
عاديين نحكي عن مشاهير في في يعني تحت
الاضواء دائما هل الناس المتابعين لهؤلاء
على يعني بكون في نظره مختلفه لهؤلاء عن
نظرتهم لاي شخص اخر فبالتالي بتاثروا بما
يجري معهم من ناحيه وزن شكل ما الى ذلك
بشكل اكبر وفي بعض الاحيان بحس بانه في
نوع من انواع الانتقام بانه يعني انت
مشهور انت
غني انت كذا انا راح احطك تحت المجهر وتحت
المراقبه وافضل يعني وبالفعل اجلدك اذا
اذا اخطات ولو قيداء نعم اكيد اكيد لانه
اذا عندي هالشخص انا عم بطلع عليك قدوه
بدي الحقه اذا عندي هالشخص ما كثير بحبه
مني كثير متواصله معه شو ما عمل بدي انتقد
يعني هيدي طبيعه البشر بس كثير مبسوطه انا
انه عم نحكي بالموضوع خليها يكون هالمنصه
لحتى نبطل نطلق الاحكام على العالم ونتقبل
العالم مثل ما هن ويكون عنا نظره شوي
شموليه لانه من سماح انور وغيرها يعني صور
رائعه انا شايفه صور جميله جدا لالها يعني
وهي حره يعني من مبدا عيش وسيبني اعيش بس
انا انا يعني هي ما تحبني باعتبارها اني
انا مغمور
شكرا
الاستشاريه في علم الذكاء العاطفي شكرا
يعطيكم العافيه
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات